can't rush the process
as long as there's an image it doesn't
have to be perfect
can't rush the process
there's a moment in Better Call Saul
season 6 episode 7 where Lalo sees a
cockroach Crawling by it reminds him of
his lawyer who he once compared to the
resilient and enduring insect and it's
reminiscent of Gus figuring out how Lalo
might get to him when he thought of
those spice curls they're small details
that can slip right by when they're
first introduced but jump out when
you're looking back trying to put
together what you just watched happen
within the story the characters
experience something similar by the end
of the mediation meeting Howard knows
exactly how he was conned just like
Chuck knew precisely what happened with
the Mesa Verde paperwork back in season
two but the schemes they were up against
were so well crafted that there wouldn't
be anything they could do about it by
the time they figured out what was
happening they get sucked in like we get
swept up and this episode got me really
excited about how the writers may have
put together the ending of this story
thank guys Pete here today I'm going to
break down the seventh episode of better
call Saul's final season it is a
mid-season finale since the show is on
break now until it Returns on July 11th
and even though writer director Thomas
tried to temper expectations about the
finale part of that before it aired the
shocking ending certainly Works in that
capacity I'll probably never look at a
flickering candle the same way again it
was a fantastic episode that he did a
great job with as expected that changes
the trajectory of things and I'll be
breaking down everything that happened
after this quick spoiler warning if you
haven't watched episode 7 of Better Call
Saul season 6 yet then this video won't
be for you and with that out of the way
let's get into it for my money this is a
nearly perfect episode of Television it
started out with a big surprise that
Lalo is already in Albuquerque we watch
his plan develop at his cool and
deliberate pace and we pick up with
Jimmy and Kim who are in a frantic race
against the clock these stories might be
happening in the same city but they
couldn't feel further apart and
everything on Kim and Jimmy's side
hinges on a character who couldn't be
further removed from the world that Lalo
and Gus inhabit different characters
different factions and different plans
but everyone does have one thing in
common they all think they know what's
going on and that they can control the
situation this is highlighted
beautifully in an early scene where
Howard startles a new hire who is there
to stock the refrigerator while we're
all thinking hey buddy don't put those
cans you just shook up in with the
others Howard calmly shows him how to
solve his problem what's more he learned
the technique when from the m in hhm
Charles McGill the fresh lawyer has no
idea who Chuck is a year and a half
after his death at least not from seeing
his image and that makes you think about
the legacy of the man who built the firm
into what it is which plays as some
uneasy foreshadowing of what's to come
for Howard Chuck knew Jimmy so well he
couldn't imagine anything going wrong
right up until the second it did Hamlin
doesn't believe he could make the same
mistake but ultimately he will as far as
D-Day is concerned the deck is stacked
against Howard in a way he wouldn't have
been able to anticipate the private
investigator he hired was indeed a plant
from Kim and Jimmy the whole time this
was something that started to become
apparent in the last episode but there
was the issue of not being able to
figure out how they would have got him
to hire the exact Pi they needed him to
it turns out they knew which agency hhm
uses for matters like this and so they
called them a receptionist telling her
they needed to update their contact
information the new number went straight
to a burner phone held by the pi Jimmy
and Kim hired and when Howard reached
out he dealt with him directly this
means he never had a chance into their
credit Jimmy and Kim's plan works
perfectly
first they have to reshoot the pictures
which is so much fun and so kinetic that
you almost forget about that Lalo teaser
Jimmy goes to convince Lenny to walk off
his shift and get some clutch
performances from the UNM film students
to recreate the bribe photographs with
the fake judge wearing a fake cast the
photo shoot starts out with this great
long sequence that plays like a Warner
where things wind up Tighter and Tighter
until it ends on a shot of Kim wrapping
the foe cast there's a couple of small
details here that lighten things up the
makeup girl is coming from rehearsal for
a live-action musical Tribute to The
Dark Crystal and if you're wondering why
the sound guy brings his boom mic to
photo shoots while someone has to make
it look like the shots were taken from
behind some cover it's notable that when
Kim shows up she refuses to head back to
Santa Fe for her meeting when Jimmy
suggests it helping those pro bono
clients is a distant memory in the midst
of the unfolding plan and later Howard
will finally lay out what's really
behind all of this sure they will get
money and it will be enough for her to
start her practice but they're really
doing this for fun this has never been
as clear as it is when they listen in on
the meeting the satisfaction of hearing
Howard's demise literally turns them on
to where they're grinding on the couch
before it's over and as mentioned it
does go off superbly the topical
solution on the pictures gets into
Howard's bloodstream as he thinks he's
being shown evidence of a bribe he
doesn't know who's in the pictures until
the judge walks into the meeting he
makes his accusation thinking he can
back it up only to have different
pictures of Jimmy handing the sound guy
who's wearing the handlebar mustache his
frisbee it's laugh out loud funny while
being devastating at the exact same time
it doesn't matter that he puts it all
together if if Cliff believes him or not
or whether Rich Schweikert is
disappointed about how it happened his
firm has to move to pressure to settle
and Cliff has to threaten Howard to
agree because there just isn't another
option I really liked how they ended
this for all the fun there was in the
lead up and how perfectly they paid off
all the setup the judge's reaction
enrich's conversation with Cliff paint a
great picture of how it looks from our
perspective there's no sense of Victory
no hooting no hollering there's no
dramatic moment with Howard nose diving
off the roof or anything like that it's
just an absolutely uncomfortable display
from The Golden Boy and we've already
peaked behind the curtains to know who
was responsible no matter how you feel
about Howard's character you can't help
but feel sad for him in that moment it
only gets worse from there Lalo has been
spending his time watching the laundry
company where Gus is building the super
lab he found out where that was from
Casper her and he makes a recording for
Donald audio revealing that he's still
alive and letting him know what Gus is
up to his plan is to kill the guards and
go inside to get that proof he's been
after but when he calls Hector he
realizes that he just gave himself away
when he hears that the phone line is
being monitored this is the rare
occasion where we see him lose his cool
but he recovers quickly after smashing
his folding chair he calls back into
Hector's dismay tells him he couldn't
find proof but will move against Gus
that night anyway this is misdirection
and he's able to see the security detail
react in real time it's not clear if he
anticipated that they were watching
Jimmy's apartment and wanted to draw
people away from there but that's what
ends up happening when Mike goes to warn
Gus he mentions that they pulled
everyone off of the low priority targets
their plan is to use Gus's two house
setup to their advantage put him in the
couple's house next door use the decoy
to make it look like he's in his house
alone and then take Lalo out when he
makes his move we'll have to wait and
see how that all plays out if it even
comes to that because he's got another
stop to make after seeing that cockroach
Kim and Jimmy are watching Classic
Movies waiting for Howard to show up
when the knock at the door happened I
half expected it to be Lolo which
provided an unexpected sense of relief
when it turned out to be Howard as Jimmy
opens the door you can't help but notice
that Kim reacts to the flicker of the
candle that's sitting on the table
Howard comes in and there's a little bit
of Kim and Jimmy acting like they don't
know what he's talking about which he
quickly points out that of course they
have to play it that way and then the
scene transcends whatever you thought it
might have been when Howard poses the
question everyone who watches the show
has been asking what did he do to
deserve this he then very succinctly
runs through all the reasons that we
know about which made me chuckle on a
personal level since they were all the
things I listed in my video a few weeks
ago it still doesn't quite make sense
and as Patrick Fabian who's always been
fantastic in the role takes things up to
another level that we've never seen he
puts it out there that they do it for
fun that they get off on it he reveals
what he really thinks about both of them
he agrees with Chuck that Jimmy can't
help himself he was born broken and will
never be different he says that he
thinks Kim is one of the smartest and
most promising human beings he's ever
known so he can't believe the choices
she's made there's a point here where he
tells her that she has a piece missing
and it feels like one of those
situations where someone tells you
something that you know to be true but
aren't willing to look at it's a telling
exchange that complicates things more
than it clears them up we know that he
has changed to become a better person
over the past few seasons but he's being
honest in the way that he looks at
people because he doesn't have anything
else to lose it's the part where Howard
gets to be right while still displaying
all the ugly parts of his character he
is all the things they think he is but
there is more to him in this episode
we've seen the good alongside the bad
and Jimmy and Kim are all the things
Howard thinks they are although the
sociopath allegation is a little
dramatic but there's more to them as
well and they did plan things out in a
way that could have worked there's a
moment where they've clearly won and
it's still true that he'll be able to
bounce back that he'll land on his feet
and he acknowledges this and we see some
of their Humanity when they react to the
news that his marriage is falling apart
it's not that they didn't plan things
out or even ignore the potential for
consequences it comes down to them not
having as much control over things as
they thought they did the same thing
they planned out to happen to Howard
happens to them and no amount of
planning could have accounted for the
situation they find themselves in when
the candle flickers again right before
that happens Howard vows to dedicate his
life to making sure everyone knows the
truth and I suppose that's a vow he's
able to keep Lalo enters the room and
Ray C horn and Bob Odenkirk match
Patrick fabian's incredible performance
when they realize what's happening the
look of Terror is so authentic and you
have to imagine for Jimmy this is like
seeing a ghost they try to get Howard to
leave but he's just getting started and
Tony Dalton sells the idea that he has
nothing to worry about even while he's
putting the silencer on his gun what
follows is a death that is absolutely
shocking even though you knew it was
going to happen it takes the idea of
Howard doesn't deserve this to a brand
new place his brains are splattered on
the painting that they use to plan out
his downfall and after he hits the
ground Lalo quiets them down and says
let's talk what happens next is
something we'll all be thinking about
until July 11th when episode 8 airs
there will be consequences it's hard to
say what those will be and it's hard to
know what Lolo has in mind for these two
that brought him over here in the first
place to me it seemed like Lalu might
have been surprised when he saw Mike
come out of the laundry and how quick
the response was maybe just how many
people were around in general it's
possible that his mistake tipped him off
that things were more dangerous than he
was expecting I also don't know how
they'll explain him never sending the
videotape to Eladio but maybe it will be
about him changing up his plans maybe
this is all related I don't know how
Jimmy and Kim fit into his plans but it
can't be good for either of them we know
what the consequences are for Howard
he's dead what's worse is that he'll
disappear with his legacy wiped away
thanks to this drug addiction narrative
that Jimmy and Kim So carefully crafted
he was the last of hhm standing so you
have to imagine that that will cease to
exist the final sequence is similar to
Drew Sharp's murder and Breaking Bad the
crazy plan works out but someone finds
themselves in the wrong place at the
wrong time I'd say it has the same
impact I'll also say again that it
doesn't matter if you like the character
or even if you were happy to see him
knocked down earlier in the episode no
one deserves what happens to him here
and Jimmy and Kim will be connected to
this since they saw it happen and won't
be able to say anything about it so just
a great episode it does all the things
that you expect Better Call Saul to do
well it looked great the performances
were stellar and it found a balance
between the funny and the dramatic there
were so many little things in this
episode that stand out that are in some
ways overshadowed by this crazy ending
what's more promising is the way they
brought things together plan an
execution addressed so many things we'd
been thinking about in the last three
episodes and delivered a confident
payoff it's also able to deliver what
you think think might happen with a
little bit of misdirection like Howard
not drinking caffeine to keep it from
being completely obvious plus it manages
to make the outcome that makes the most
sense still feel exciting which I guess
is really important when you're making a
prequel it was all really satisfying
little things like the pi being in on it
which was on the board to see if you go
back and look and big things like how
will this plan go wrong and what will
the unintended consequences be at the
beginning of the Season we had four
characters whose endings we weren't sure
about so far nacho and Howard's stories
both came to memorable ends and we still
have two to go I feel like my confidence
for how those will end is at an all-time
high regardless of which direction they
decide to go in there's so much more to
talk about but I think this is a good
place to leave things for this video
we'll be talking more about this episode
on Tuesday night in the live stream at
9pm Eastern and I'll have a couple of
other videos videos out later this week
for now let me know in the comments what
you thought about this episode if you
thought the payoff was worth the setup
and what you think will happen next
please like this video If you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon